en guyane aux avocats franco-américain
président des républicains sauveur 6
france bonjour et merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france une quarantaine
de couvre-feu imposé aux états unis la
totalité de la garde nationale du
minnesota mobiliser des états d'urgence
décrétés dans plusieurs états ce sursaut
sécuritaire c'est la seule réponse pour
retrouver le calme dans le pays
je pensais jamais on repense affaire est
entendu vous avez vu le premier un jour
qui essaie d'apaiser les calmes et à
toutes les différents réseaux pire les
médias des différents gouverneurs et les
maires de villes en villes concernées
mais ça n'a pas arrêté les violences et
les 1 minute 10 minutes sont aggravées
ils sont répandus dans plusieurs villes
du pays tombent aujourd'hui on est
confronté à des émeutes au niveau
national et aujourd'hui il faut qu'il
retrouve le calme pendant l trump cible
comme on l'a entendu à les anarchistes
les radicaux de gauche responsable selon
lui des émeutes est ce que ce n'est pas
la tenter de détourner l'attention à ce
que le souffle pas sur les braises de
division par 10 partisane est ce que
vous vous n'attendez pas des finalement
une posture beaucoup plus rassembleuse
vous savez pourquoi il a visé les
antilles sa langue en plus ils utilisent
les réseaux sociaux pour organiser les
différents mouvements et les différentes
stratégies à travers le pays pour
provoquer et organiser les habitants du
centre ville et c'est assez passait bien
en france et systra deschamps est usée
par les berges bogue a et les autres à
gauche ici en france et à travers
l'europe et y travaillent ensemble et
des liens les différents services de
sécurité du pays des états unis et de
l'europe connaît ces stratégies sont en
contact avec l'un et nothomb ces
interrogations sont fondés par notre
président il faut regarder aussi du
conte démocrates mais je parle d'une est
resté presque trois jours
silencieux des ventes ces émeutes cette
violence où tous les américains sont
concernés
il ya des morts du côté des américains
mais aussi des morts des hommes blancs
qui sont lynchés des femmes larcher
était les meilleurs mais
assez en avant donc on il faut montrer
la ville entend tout
c'est aspect si on voulait objectifs par
rapport à ce qui se passe aux etats unis
est aujourd'hui des manques la glace
silencieux par rapport à ça il laisse
les violences montée et autres questions
cette situation qu'on vit en ce moment
aux états unis va nécessairement poser
sur le scrutin présidentiel de novembre
on l'entend à lorsque vous parlais à
l'instant de jaude hayden que proposent
les républicains que vous représentez
ici pour remédier aux fortes disparités
sociales aux etats-unis beaucoup les met
en avant pour expliquer aujourd'hui ces
violences qui secoue le pays je pense
que voudrait savoir remettre les choses
dans les contextes où des tirs 30 a fait
depuis 40 ans l'économie était à sa
hauteur
donc c'est un record et il faut 10 mai
dans un contexte avant l'écho vie
aujourd'hui on vient de sortir
d'inscription qu'ovide et on a un énorme
chômage record suite à la gestion à des
dépôts vite qu'ils essaient de
l'information que bien entendu il ya des
comptes qui vont les cheminots graves
seront comptés ce qui s'est passé et qui
toute l'économie mondiale était mis un
genou à cause de cette situation
donc aujourd'hui laisse les dirigeants
étaient confinés la situation est
explosive
aujourd'hui c'était un risque à bien
entendu suite à nos compliments père de
travail
les gens sont des situations désespérées
et on a aussi des problèmes sur les
différents problèmes de déconfinement
aux états unis il ya des politiques il
au jt ont été mis en place par dix
gouverneurs démocrates dans certains
états et aujourd'hui on subit les
conséquences et il ya beaucoup
d'américains qui ont subi ces espaces et
cette situation très très difficile et
qu'on voudra mais les problèmes des
luttes des classes on n'apprend pas pour
atteindre ces 8es acpr est la plus
grande place aux paris économies avant
la situation des copies les manifestants
demandent que justice soit faite on le
rappelle il a quand même fallu attendre
plusieurs jours avant que le policier
mis en cause dans la mort de georges
floyd elle soit inculpé d'homicide
involontaire il passera donc en comparu
sur la semaine prochaine
c'est là un nouveau contre le policier
qui tourne au drame comment est-ce qu'on
peut mettre un terme à de tels
agissements sans la police américaine
vous servez des aux états unis sait pas
comment excuse moi c'est pas comme en
france en france à la police nationale
et gendarmerie est géré au niveau et
centralisées par l'état on est aux états
unis chaque état à chatila ces propos
visent donc à minneapolis c'est la ville
qui gère les policiers et cela file et
j'aurais pas des démocrates et l'état et
géré par des démocrates ils auraient dû
les autorités précisant qu occupe lui
faire dès le début
il aurait pu l'inculpé continue d'être
enceinte disent qu'ils ont eu peu aux
lieux ils ont laissé les choses passées
et ce sous la pression à suite aux
émeutes qui ils ont occupé
d'habitude ils ont assez d'éléments pour
pouvoir arrêter et en mois mais en
insistant comme ils ont fait tout de
suite mais en tout cas il y avait assez
d'éléments pour faire mais la passion de
ces policiers et les faits qu'ils ont
retardé la réaction policière et pénales
par rapport à situation a provoqué et on
irait à 30 et des violences à robben
curieux et je pense que c'est une
mauvaise réaction de la part des
autorités à minnesota à minneapolis
il aurait pu faire ça tout de suite au
montreux petit et faire contre cette
violence et qu'ils ont pris trop de
temps donc ça c'est une question de
politique interne de chaque vie et des
sharks et a donc on peut pas faire
d'amalgamé au niveau des niveaux
national parce que des polices n'est pas
géré au niveau national merci et
beaucoup rendiez alors je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat franco américain
président des républicains sauveur 6
france